Neera wrote in saying david is the term
flyover States offensive let's take this
in two parts number one I don't really
love the term offensive as a criticism
of an idea because it's not a criticism
of an idea right that that's number one
and I know that sometimes I reflexively
use the word offensive even though my
prevailing view is being offended is not
a defense and it is not an argument and
it doesn't change the fact so in general
the idea of analyzing whether something
is offensive or not I don't really love
but I think that the more broad question
here is is it an insult to those who
live in what are called flyover States
to call them flyover States to some
degree it is I mean it's it's not I
listen I've made clear on the first
bonus show back earlier this week when I
got back from California at the parts of
this country that I would really
consider living in that I like from all
the different places I've been to and
I've been to quite a few places although
I've never been you know to the Dakotas
or to Montana I have not been everywhere
but I've been to a variety of places the
places I would really see myself living
or mostly mostly on the coast I think
exclusively other than like Austin Texas
which I mentioned a liberal elitist
right exactly so I do think that in that
I am sort of implicitly criticizing
elements of what happens in flyover
country I don't see myself really having
too much in common with people in the
rural South or small cities in the
center of the country I've been to
Kansas City I've been to st. Louis I've
been to some of these other places
Cleveland I I don't see myself living
there is it an insult about the people
no it can be right for them and not
right for me so conceptually you know I
wouldn't say that the term flyover
States is an insult to the people but it
is a sort of write off by people the
coastal elites which I probably am one
of to say there's just really nothing
there for me well I think when we hear
the terms flyover States or flyover
country it's it's said by
a politician right who's saying that we
can't forget about these people
sometimes but certainly when they use it
they're not doing it in an offensive way
it's actually anything complimentary and
offensive yeah yeah I don't know I guess
I know that there are people in those
states who find it to be an insult I
think that it's not so much an insult
about them but a criticism of what life
is like there it wouldn't be for me
that's for sure
and even in in more urban areas cities
in the center of the country I still
find that the culture is just not for me
it's really not and I don't mean it as
an insult when I talk about a lot of the
country being flyover country although
it's not a term I really use it I'm
comfortable using it it's not an insult
about the people it's just me saying
it's not for me and it wouldn't really
work for me you can also call flyover
country America's heartland yes
but does that mean that the coasts
aren't part of real America are those
the elitist liberals out there in San
Francisco and Boston I mean listen I
mean can you take offense of that too I
thought yeah the places I like and I
agreed that that's not actually most of
America at least by geographical area
geographically speaking most of this
country our places I couldn't see myself
living in ever and that don't resonate
with my values and priorities so from a
geographical standpoint yeah places like
Miami and New York City and Boston and
San Francisco and Los Angeles they are
actually the outliers they are actually
the exception in terms of population in
terms of ideology maybe less so although
still we know that geographically red
states Heartland ideas do have an
advantage and I think there's an
argument to be made for both but I will
continue using the term flyover States
because I do think that it encompasses a
lot of what we're sort of talking about
politically right without it actually
being an insult it's like they get left
behind they get myth I mean you just fly
over them you don't actually visit those
states I mean it all starts to look very
similar from 37,000 feet I saw
experience that after basically once you
get away from the Mount
flying home from San Francisco to Boston
once you get past the Rockies there it
starts to look pretty damn similar other
than the occasional city that you see
down below basically from you know just
past the Rockies all the way back to
Boston almost it's stuck in a cloud it's
all white at that point to middle the
country at that point it's all exactly
the same sure the relevance of that is
questionable to me but we'll go with it
all right that's it for today keep
sending in your questions we've got a
great bonus show for you today two ways
to access the bonus show david
pakman.com slash membership patreon.com
slash david pakman show